this is kind of making the rounds bill
burr is out here love it uh it's really
great love it it was this is the this is
the effect of like saying something that
everybody feels yes right
uh
he says literally for a minute on his
podcast just about how shitty cnn is
right of a channel right and
this one minute kind of explodes
he not only shits on cnn he says msnbc
fox news he says they're all the [ __ ]
same thing they're un american they're
treasonous their uh ratings have tanked
in this massive way i think like cnn
ratings are down 68 or something like
that i think fox is down like 27 too but
like without trump there's this void in
interest for the news yeah now nothing
is newsworthy we don't really give a
[ __ ] anymore yeah so they need trump so
they're starting to talk about trump and
then his whole thing was
by talking about him giving him all this
free air time you're going to get him
elected again and you want it you want
darth vader because you need it for your
relevance yes you know my mother-in-law
comes over to help watch the kids and uh
she always puts on cnn and do you know
what those [ __ ] morons are doing
do you know what those [ __ ] morons
are doing
they're [ __ ] talking about trump
i swear to god i cannot believe people
watch that channel this they're so dumb
it's like do you think these people give
a [ __ ]
who's pre they want darth vader to come
back they want him to come back because
they got nothing to talk about because
it's show business and joe biden is a
[ __ ] boar
they can't [ __ ] about him because he's
wearing a blue tie so now what do they
do
they're going out there they're doing
what they did the first time to get this
guy elected by giving them all this free
coverage
while they act like they allegedly don't
like him
i don't buy it
i don't buy it they're a corporate news
channel and they just they're just
they're [ __ ] treasonous un-american
pieces of [ __ ] just like fox news msnbc
just like all of them
just like [ __ ] all of them
i was at the gym the other day right you
know
oh [ __ ] billy big boobs right
i'm on the elliptical and they had cnn
on with the sound down and i wanted to
ask him can you turn the [ __ ] channel
no they didn't have the sound down they
made it seem like all of california was
on fire which i know it is
but like there's nothing i could do
about it
all right and then then they go okay and
then uh now let's talk covet and the
numbers are up
it's just like what what is their
[ __ ] deal on those on those channels
don't they have any idea what they're
doing to you cycle here i am at the
[ __ ] gym trying to work off a bunch
of goddamn ice cream sundaes
and all i get is [ __ ] fires
and pandemic [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] you know
how about a positive story i swear to
god if i ran a 24-hour news network
you know our brand would be we give you
too bad but we still give you one good
two steps back but one step forward
give you a couple of good stories
you do a story that involves uh race
relations where people are actually
getting along
well that doesn't get ratings
you have to make them feel like [ __ ]
you have to scare the hell out of them
you got to make them feel like they got
a virus their house is gonna burn down
and uh and that the [ __ ] the nazis
are coming back
to us those are the tent poles that make
for a great
uh uh
half hour news
if they don't have a gun in their mouth
by 18 minutes in then then we're not
doing our job i think that that's what
they say
you know
can you imagine that was your [ __ ]
job you just go on tv every day and lie
and
get people to be against each other and
just
have everybody just sort of walking
around in a low to high level of
hysteria
it's like [ __ ]
like the guys in the nhl whose job it is
to go out there and stir it up you know
slashing and [ __ ]
sparing people and the refs not looking
just pissing people off let's get a
little chippy out there that that's how
the news channels like it they want it
to be a little chippy
you know be a great [ __ ] prank
is to somehow
like hack into them
they're whatever their news feed is and
it's just nothing but good news
and just watch to see if they could do
it
because everything they're saying
anyways is biased right so who gives a
[ __ ] if you lie about it right that's
what everybody's doing on the internet
aren't they they're goddamn [ __ ]
instagram pages
holding your phone up
so you up your number you're a four but
you want to look like a six so you
stretch your little [ __ ] t-rex arms
up over your [ __ ]
slightly above average size head
so it doesn't look as big
like look at her way down there
she's cute as a button
ground's coming up ground's coming up
[ __ ] she's a four
[Music]
[Applause]